fantastic news that nazanin is out at
last and i
am thrilled for her i'm thrilled uh also
for
uh anusha ashuri and and
taba morad who
are also out
and
it's been a lot of
work by
a lot of people uh i want to pay a
particular tribute in the case of
nazanin
to her her husband richard and it's
fantastic that she'll be now able to
come back and and see her family see her
daughter gabriella uh and
um i i should also thank some of the
people who've worked hard the uh the
amani's uh have been very useful and uh
i i thank them i think
a huge team has been on it for a long
time and do you feel a particular
pleasure at it because when you were
foreign secretary sometimes you were
criticized for making the situation
worse for her or you know as the leader
of the uk when this has finally happened
is it particularly gratifying i think
it's one i think it's it's wonderful
news and
i i think that the
uh
we must always realize that
uh sadly the the
regime in tehran is capable of of
holding people in in this way i think
people do need to to to recognize that
and i'm glad that after a great deal of
uk diplomacy we've been able to uh to to
get her out get her back uh to her
family and i'm i'm absolutely thrilled
for uh for nazanin for richard and for
gabriella